el Ministerio de relaciones exteriores
de Perú anunció que los países de la
alianza del Pacífico acordaron que a
partir de hoy chile ejercerá la
presidencia pro tempore del organismo
por su parte el canciller de chile
Alberto banquele beren afirmó que desde
el primero de agosto Perú asumirá la
presidencia de la alianza del Pacífico
en un comunicado la cancillería peruana
señaló que el acuerdo de los países
miembros refleja la voluntad política de
seguir apostando por la integración al
respecto alcancía r Perú Luis González
posada dijo que es irresponsable que el
presidente mexicano Andrés Manuel López
Obrador reduce entregar la presidencia
de la alianza del Pacífico al Perú y
acusó al mandatario mexicano de querer
sabotear el mecanismo integrador
Mientras tanto el gobierno de la
presidenta Dina boluarte no ha decidido
todavía responder a su embajador en
México y por el momento no habrá cambio
en las relaciones bilaterales una fuente
de la cancillería de esta nación andina
me señaló que una cosa es la alianza del
Pacífico y otra las relaciones
diplomáticas dañadas por Andrés Manuel
López Obrador quien por sus palabras
ofensivas al Perú y sus constantes
ataques e injerencias seguirá siendo
persona no grata para esta nación